our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us New
Jersey State Trooper Michael Patterson
pulled over a retired officer earlier
this month Michelle Miller shows how
that chance encounter actually led to a
reunion that was 27 years in the making
Michelle good morning good morning it's
the moment every driver dreads being
pulled over by a police officer and
while trooper Patterson began the
traffic stop with great roadside manner
it ended with a twist
neither man expected how's it going
today with his body cam rolling trooper
Michael Patterson pulled over a white
BMW for what he thought was a routine
traffic stop after some small talk
retired police officer Matthew Bailey
realized they were from the same
neighborhood and it crossed paths before
thanks to the troopers mom I was in
labor and didn't realize it before you
know I'm on the bed and Michael's head
is crowning every birthday Michael's
mother recounted the story of how an
officer helped his dad deliver him at
home at the house I'm like wow is this
really happening right now I just
extended my hand I said sir that was me
hey that was me my name is Michael
Patterson it's a pleasure to meet you
and thank you for helping deliver me so
this is the home where Michael was born
and raised Matthew Michael and his mom
had a chance to return to the scene of
his birth 27 years later what was going
through your mind at that point I didn't
have any children of my own I had never
seen and experienced it and I was just
trying to recall Academy days of my
training they trained in the Academy for
this brief segment
but the reunion of the families almost
didn't happen I'm not thinking about you
know hey why don't you get out of the
car let's take a picture together that's
not true but our drove over to his house
it wasn't far from the car stop and I
wrote him a note I left it on his door I
said sir you know my name is Michael
Patterson the true but I just stopped
you
my family suggested that we take
pictures together so you know if you
don't mind you know just give me a call
at your earliest convenience and maybe
we'll connect he got that picture and a
lot more I haven't been there yet try it
it's good I'm grateful to mr. Bailey for
coming to assist and everyone asked why
I get so upset I get upset because I
honestly don't know what would have
happened had they not come to my aid so
I just want to tell mr. bill I
appreciate him coming yeah absolutely it
was my pleasure great experience I think
a greater power somehow made that
meeting happen and I'm not sure where
it's gonna take us and willing to go on
the journey we're definitely gonna stay
in touch because this is a special
relationship it's a special relationship
and it was meant to happen things just
don't randomly happen like that yeah
some people might call this serendipity
what do you call it purpose yes
purpose indeed well needless to say
Bailey was not ticketed for those tinted
windows the universe has seemed to want
to bring these two together for a very
long time when Michael was about 10
years old they ran into each other in a
grocery store that meaning didn't leave
much of an impression on young Michael
but this time I think might be the charm
Gail I'll say I love that story but I
also love Michelle's expressions like
Thank You mr. Bailey I thought she was
gonna start crying such a beautiful
story mom cuz you know she's just
thinking man thank God for that officer
a beautiful story Patterson Bay Laurie